- This season has been so fun,
I cannot wait for everybody
to see these blinds
'cause I feel like since you
are sitting next to Blake
you two and the banter is so funny.
- The gloves came off.
- You give him crap
right back and not a lot
of people hang there.
- I learned that you have
to preempt his crap giving.
- Oh my God,
you, you nailed it.
- And just jump him,
beat him to it.
- Gosh, it was good.
- Yeah.
It's been a lot of fun.
- It was
literally my favorite
blinds we've ever shot.
- Really?
- Yeah,
I told the producers, I
was like, this was my,
it felt like I was
getting paid to have fun.
Like I was like, this is awesome.
- That's perfect.
I was going home at night
and I was like, I love my jobs.
Well, your brother Frankie has
become a giant TikTok star.
How proud are you of that?
That's cool.
- Very proud.
I think it's amazing.
He, he's always had a really unique
sense of humor and a unique
voice as a comedic person.
There he is, look at him,
he's just brilliant.
(laughing)
And he's you know,
he's the star world, just
Frankie's brothers now.
- I, I'm gonna tell you what
I am tempted to say he might
be my favorite brother.
(laughing)
- He's certainly mine.
- I was like, oh my gosh.
The money with the twerking.
- It's next level.